in this video you're going to learn how
to do the transformation of parent
functions and this is going to be an
introduction uh to doing this and the
first thing we want to talk about is
what are the parent functions and what
are some key points that you might want
to know uh for those parent functions
and then we're going to talk about some
of the Transformations and then we're
going to get into four examples where we
can practice so the first thing is you
might want to take a screenshot of this
this is what you're going to want to
really be familiar with you might want
to memorize it and refer back to it so
go aead and take a screenshot I'll try
to get out of the way here okay you got
it okay so now let's talk about the
different types of parent functions a
parent function is kind of like the core
function when everything else is kind of
removed from it so if we think of this
yal x^2 we call that a quadratic and it
has this u-shaped graph it's a parabola
and you're going to want to know these
key points these are some easy numbers
all I'm doing is I'm squaring them and
that's how I'm getting these y values I
pick small numbers because they're
easier to work with you've got your
cubic function F kind of looks like this
shape here and you can see I'm using a
couple negative zero and a couple
positive and then I'm cubing them the
square root function notice I'm picking
these numbers 0 1 49 because they're
easy to take the square root of we get 0
1 2 3 notice the square root function
just goes in that One Direction there
and then the cube root function you can
see this three tells us it's a cube root
I picked a few negative and a few
positive and zero and I picked numbers
that are easy to take the cube root of
the reciprocal function it approaches
the X y AIS these are vertical and
horizontal asmp tootes and I'm picking a
couple negative zero and a couple
positive of course we can't divide by
zero that's undefined that's why we're
getting that vertical ASM toote there
and then the absolute value function
remember I picked a couple negative Z
and a couple positive the absolute value
always makes those outputs positive we
get this real sharp V type shape as
opposed to the parabola which is more of
a u-shape graph okay so those are the
basic graphs now we're going to be
working with Transformations when
they're in this form
now what exactly does this mean well you
can see if I cover up this H and this K
and this a I'm really just left with x²
that's the parent function or the core
function but let's talk about what do
the a the H and the K do well if you
take the absolute value of this number
here in front if it's greater than one
so for example this was a two or a three
or a four we call that a vertical
stretch so it's like you're multiplying
all the Y values by that a number and
it's going to stretch it making it go up
faster okay you're pulling it in the y
direction now if that a value the
absolute value of that a value is
between zero and one say for example if
it was a half or a third or fourth then
we call it a vertical shrink so we're
like squeezing it towards the x- axis so
we're multiplying all the Y values by
this number so if it's a half we
multiply all the numbers in our table
the Y values here by a half not the X
values just the yv values because it's a
vertical strink and if the number itself
the a value itself is negative meaning
Less Than Zero what it does is it takes
all these positive yv values and makes
them the opposite which reflects it over
the x-axis you can multiply all these yv
values by negative one to get the new
y-coordinates and then the H value
that's the number here that's grouped
with the X now whatever is grouped with
the X now when I say group with the X
sometimes students get a little confused
it's like in the parentheses or
underneath the square root or kind of
like in the denominator here or inside
the absolute value bars it's like
grouped with that x value it's going to
have what we call the opposite effect
the quote unquote opposite effect what
do I mean by that well if it's x minus
one we're actually going to shift to the
graph not negative 1 but positive one to
the right if this was x + one then I
would actually shift at the opposite way
you see negative one to the left so
remember whatever is group of the X has
like the opposite effect and then if
it's not group of the X like this K
value here that's going to shift the
graph up or down it has the same effect
meaning if K was five I would shift this
graph up five if it was minus five I'd
shift it down five now keep in mind if
it's grouped with the X it's affecting
the X Direction the horizontal Direction
which means that if I was shifting right
one I would add one to all these x
coordinates here in my table or I could
just pick up the graph and move it one
to the right but over here with this K
value that's affecting the vertical
direction that means I'm going to be
adding or subtracting that K value from
these y-coordinates we're going to do
four examples so you're going to see how
this works but again take a screenshot
and you're going to refer back to this
so let's go ahead and dive into those
examples now okay number one we've got Y
= 2 * the quantity x - 1^ 2 + 3 so what
is the parent function well again if we
cover up the one the three and the two
you can see we're left with X squar
that's our parent function our quadratic
function it's a U-shaped graph it's a
parabola and remember these key numbers
-2 1 0 1 2 I'm just squaring them here
to get 4 1
014 but now we're going to talk about
how do I get the actual graph written
here when you do the order of
Transformations and they're in this form
like this an easy way to do it is just
to work from left to right okay so what
we could do is we could do the vertical
stretch or Shrink first then we could
shift it left or right then we could
shift it up or down now you can also do
this uh horizontal shift left or right
and then the vertical stretch but you
always want to make sure when it's in
this form that you do this K value or
the vertical shift up or down last okay
otherwise you're going to get a
different uh graph in some situations so
let's talk about that here so if I look
at this two here I can see this is
greater than one which tells me it's a
vertical stretch by a factor of two when
I think about vertical I'm thinking the
y direction see this y- AIS Direction so
I'm going to multiply all these
y-coordinates by two giving us 8 2 0 2
and 8 all I'm doing is multiplying by
two cross out the old y values then we
see okay this minus one has the opposite
effect because it's group with the X
it's going to shift it in the xais
direction but instead of negative one
it's going to go right one now when I
think about right one I think about my X
values I'm adding one to these X
values so I'm just going to cross out
the old ones lastly the plus three it's
not group of the X that's going to
affect the y direction it has the same
effect the plus three is going to shift
it up three that's affecting the Y
values y controls up and down so I'm
going to add three to all
these Y coordinates okay now let's go
ahead and plot these points here we've
got -11 which is kind of going off my
graph here so let's go to 0 five 1 2 3 4
five I've got 1 three one two three I've
got two five 1 two 3 4 five and then
I've got 311 which is going off the
graph here a little bit so you can see
here's our Parabola notice it's a little
bit narrower because we stretched it
vertically by a factor of two it's been
shifted right one and up three and
that's our graph now if this was a -2
the negative would have taken the
original graph and reflected it over the
x-axis making it open down but in this
case positive2 it's still opening up
we're just stretching it let's take a
look at another example okay for number
two we've got y = -2 * the quantity x +
2 cubus 4 what's the parent function
here well again if you cover up the two
the4 the -2 you see how you're left with
X cubed so this is a cubic parent
function and that's why I'm picking
these numbers in my table here -2 cubed
is8 1 cubed is 1 0 Cub is 0 1 cubed is 1
2 cubed is 8 now let's look at the
transformation so when it's in this form
like this second one here we can work
from left to right or we could do the H
and then the A and then the K but make
sure we do that K last so in this case I
can see that we've got a negative here
and what the negative does is it
reflects it over the x-axis okay it's
going to make all the yv values the
opposite which means I'm going to
multiply all these yv values by negative
1 so that's going to make this positive
positive zero would stay zero negative
negative now the 1/2 okay because that's
between zero and one that's going to be
a vertical shrink by a factor of 1/2
when we think of vertical we think of
it's affecting the Y's so I'm going to
multiply all these y values by 1/2
cross out the old ones the plus two it's
grouped with the X which remember when
it's group of the X it's going to affect
the X values left and right the
horizontal Direction but remember it has
the quote unquote opposite effect plus
two means it's going to go -2 or left
two so what I can do is I can subtract
two from all of these X
values cross out the old ones and lastly
the minus 4 that has the same effect
it's not group of the X it's affecting
the Y values minus 4 is going to shift
it down four so I'm going to subtract
four from each of
these y values
here cross out the old ones okay now
let's go ahead and plot these and see
what we get so we get -4 0 which is
right about here we get -3 and a uh -33
and A2 which is right about here we get
-2
24 which is right about here and -1
-42 which is right about here and then
08 which is 2 3 4 five six 7even
somewhere right about here so the
graph's going to look
roughly like this okay now remember the
original
graph look like this but because the
negative we reflected it so instead of
going up to the right now it's going
down to the right and then we're
shifting it left well then We Shrunk it
a little bit vertical shrink by a half
then we shifted it left two and down
four let's look at number three now this
one if we cover up the three and the one
we're dealing with a square root graph
right so this is our square root graph
which normally remember looks like this
but now let's do the transformation so
the three it's a vertical stretch by a
factor of three which means we're going
to multiply all the Y values by Three
cross out those old y values there's
nothing grouped with the X there's
nothing with that X underneath that
square root so it's not shifting the
graph left or right but the plus one
it's going to shift the graph up one
remember if it's not grouped with the X
it's affecting the Y values plus one
goes up one if it was negative one it
would go down one has the same effect so
I'm just going to add
one to all these y-coordinates so now
all I have to do is plot 01 which would
be right here A 1 4 1 2 3 4 right here 4
7 1 2 3 4 1 two 3 4 five six 7 it's
easier on graph paper but we get the
right idea here and then 9 10 is
somewhere over there so basically you
can see there's our graph that's been
transformed let's take a look at one
more example okay if you're getting the
hang of this you might want to pause the
video and see if you can try this one on
your own first and then we'll go through
it together and you can kind of see how
you did so the first thing would be to
analyze what is our parent function here
well you can see if I cover up the -2
and the three I'm left with y equals
cube root of x and some good numbers
remember for cube root of x from that
first part of the video would be
negative 8 cube of8 is -2 cube of NE 1
is 1 cube of 0 is 0 cube of 1 is 1 and
cubot of 8 is two but now let's look at
this so a negative that reflects it over
the xaxis it makes all the Y values the
opposite so I'm going to multiply all
these y values
by1 so that's going to change the signs
the two now see when you look at the a
value you want to take the absolute
value see absolute value that's this one
right here we're working with and you
can see absolute value of this is going
to be positive2 which is greater than
one so we know it's a vertical stretch
so we're pulling it in the y direction
the y- axis Direction and that's going
to multiply all these yv values by two
so that's going to be 4 2 0 -2 and4 now
you might be saying Mario couldn't you
just do it all in one Fell Swoop and
multiply all the y- values by -2 you
could do that you get the same result I
just did it in steps I did the negative
and then I did the two okay now the plus
three you see that's grouped with the X
it's underneath this radical here this
cube root when it's grouped with the X
remember it has the opposite effect so
you would think intuitively you would
say well plus three that that means like
I would go to the right three like 1 two
three positive three to the right but
this one has the opposite effect it's
shifting at left three which means that
I'm going to subtract three from the X
values okay so this is going to be1 11
-4 -3 uh -2
and um 5 right cross out the old x value
so now we've got our coordinates we can
graph our graph keep in mind the
original graph the yal cube root of x
looks like that
so14 by the way notice there's not a k
value so it hasn't shifted up or down so
K value is like zero here so let's plot
these
points14 might go off our graph a little
bit let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
four 1 2 3 4 right about here and then
we've got4 2 1 2 3 4 1 two right about
there -3 0 right about there -2
-2 and 54 3 4 5 somewhere right about
here okay so you can see our
graph looks something like that
roughly and notice that only goes up to
the right but because the negative we
reflected it so it's going kind of down
to the right like that the two is
stretching it vertically and then we
shifted at left three so great job
there's a lot involved with
Transformations if you want to learn
more and go deeper into some more
challenging ones just uh even Beyond
these follow me over to that video right
there and we'll get some more practice
I'll see you over in that video